You can't resist talking about one final optimization. Looking at
this load method, notice how the translation to the physical
address and cache look-up happen in sequence. We could speed
up our implementation if we could find a way to do
this in parallel. At first this might seem impossible. After
all, the cache is indexed by the physical address We don't
know this until we've done the translation. Recall, however, that
only the higher order bits are changed when we go from
the virtual address to the physical address. The offsets
within the page stays exactly the same. Which bits are
important for extracting data from the cache? Well it's
these middlest bits that come after the offset for the
cache block. As long as the index bits for
the cache don't extend beyond the offset for the page,
this little red line here, then we can extract data
from the cache. Before we know the full physical address.
Conceptually, we're going to do something like
this where the virtual page number
goes to the TLB and the page offset goes to the cache. The
tag, or tags in the said associative case, then gets compared with
the page frame number from the TLB, and the correct data is returned.